Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Nico Willig, er ist Trainer bei der U19, das VfB Stuttgart und er war auch Trainer der Profis in den letzten Spielen, bis hin dann zur Relegation im Letzten. Ja, darüber sprechen wir jetzt im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, zum Kurzpass Nummer 141, der entstand am Rande des Mercedes-Benz Junior Cups und damit wissen die erfahrenen Hörerinnen und Hörer unter euch schon. Ich war dort nicht primär für den Rasenfunk, sondern ich war da in einer beruflichen Funktion. Das heißt, wenn es euch jetzt stören würde, dass ich das quasi so als Seitenprojekt dort gemacht habe und ich könnte jetzt ja ganz, ganz positiv gebiased sein, hinsichtlich derjenigen, die mich dahin dann ja auch eingeladen haben, dann macht jetzt hier Schluss. Wenn euch aber das Gespräch mit Nico Willig, seines Zeichens U19-Trainer des VfB Stuttgart interessiert, dann sollt ihr dranbleiben. Eben nur aus Transparenzgründen der Hinweis, das ist im sonst ja werbefreien Rasenfunk am Rande des JuniorCups entstanden, für den ich eben dann in anderer beruflicher Funktion war als für den Rasenfunk. Dort habe ich aber getroffen, wie schon im letzten Jahr, Nico Willig. Und der hat ja eine bemerkenswerte Karriere hingelegt, denn von der U19 ging es im Frühjahr des letzten Jahres zu den Profis des VfB Stuttgart. Er sollte nach Markus Weinzierl versuchen, den Karren irgendwie noch aus dem Abstiegskeller zu ziehen. Es ist nicht ganz gelungen. Es ging in die Relegation und dann ist man nach zwei Spielen gegen den 1. FC Union Berlin abgestiegen in die 2. Liga und Nico Willig wieder zurück zu U19 gekehrt. Und weil ich eben schon das Vergnügen hatte, letztes Jahr mit ihm zu sprechen, kam auch diese Aufnahme zustande. Wir haben gesprochen, wieder unter leicht anderen akustischen Bedingungen, als ihr es im Rasenfunk gewöhnt seid. Aber das ist eben einfach bei einer solchen Vorortaufnahme so. Unter anderem eben über diese paar Wochen Bundesliga-Erfahrung für ihn und was das vielleicht auch für seine Arbeit mit der U19 bedeutet und dann auch ein bisschen über generelle Fragen des Nachwuchsfußballs, über die ich unter anderem nach meinem letzten Gespräch mit ihm nachgedacht habe. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß mit diesem kleinen Kurzpass. Es deutet sich an, irgendwann müssen wir auch mal was Längeres mit Nico Willig machen, wenn er sich schon immer die Zeit für uns nimmt. Ich hoffe, die Folge gefällt euch. Feedback könnt ihr wie immer unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de hinterlassen. Und auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr auch all unsere anderen Folgen, unter anderem auch das erwähnte Tribünen-Gespräch mit Holger Badstuber. Aber jetzt gehen wir rein. Ich verabschiede mich quasi aus dem Studio. Und ihr könnt jetzt gleich das hören, was ich mit Nico Willig vor Ort in Sindelfingen besprochen habe. Viel Spaß damit. Neben mir sitzt ein alter Bekannter des Rasenfunks, Nico Willig, seines Zeichens wieder Trainer der U19, des VfB Stuttgart. Zwischendurch aber auch, so wie er es gerade genannt hat, Feuerwehrmann der Profimannschaft. Hallo Nico, schön, dass du wieder hier bist. Lass uns zuerst, weil es ein so besonderes Jahr war, auf das letzte Jahr nochmal zurückblicken. Wie hast du denn jetzt auch mit einigem Abstand die Monate vor allem im Frühjahr erlebt, als du dann plötzlich Relegation trainieren musstest? Durftest, wie auch immer.
Ja, ich durfte auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, dass es auch eine Ehre war, dass der Verein da in dem Moment auf mich zukam. Hätte ich im Januar eine Glasgugel geschaut, wäre es sicherlich nicht das drin gewesen, dass ich dann im Sommer der kurzzeitige Profi-Trainer bin, mit der Profimannschaft vier Mal zu Null spiele und trotzdem absteige. Und dann damit auch der Abstiegstrainer deutlich gekrönt bin, hätte ich nicht gedacht. Trotzdem ist es natürlich eine aufregende Zeit, eine aufregende Geschichte, die nur der Fußball schreibt. Leider ist es eben im Sport auch so. Es gibt nicht wie jeden Sonntagabend ein Happy End, sondern es gibt Gewinner und Verlierer. Das war für den VfB als Verein ein massiver Rückschlag, da abzusteigen. Das hat mich dann auch als Trainer, der in dieses Projekt reinging, gesagt hat, okay, Feuerwehrmann, ich haue alles rein, ich will das machen, ich will das schaffen, ich habe da schon Ideen dazu. Auch für mich, nach den sechs Wochen, war erst mal Akku und Energie einfach nicht mehr da. Ich habe mich gefreut, dass meine U19-Parallel noch sehr erfolgreich war, aber das hat mich schon auch dann, ja auch, ein Teil der Tränen ist vielleicht zu extrem, aber es hat mich auf jeden Fall erst mal down gemacht und ich habe mir eine gewisse Zeit gebraucht, um mich davon auch wieder zu erholen in gewisser Weise, weil das war schon mit Herz und Seele dabei und ich wollte das schaffen. In der Regel erreiche ich die Ziele sportlich, zumindest glaube ich das, und da ist es leider nicht gelungen, und die Auswirkungen waren natürlich gravierend. Und trotzdem, wie gesagt, das ist Sport und man muss dann auch wieder aufstehen und ein halbes Jahr später bin ich jetzt wieder gerne hier als U19-Trainer und mache übrigens meinen zweiten Podcast in meinem Leben.
Ja, da haben wir vorhin schon drüber geredet und der erste hier im Rasenfunk hat zu Reaktionen geführt. Da können wir ja jetzt gespannt sein, was jetzt passiert. Da werden viele Zuschriften wieder kommen. Aber sag mir doch mal, was war denn der größte Unterschied tatsächlich dann von der U19 zu den Profis in diesen sechs wilden Wochen, die es da für dich gab? War es die Medienaufmerksamkeit? War es der Druck? Was hat sich da vor allem für dich verändert?
Die Ansprache und die Arbeit mit der Mannschaft, die waren sich sehr, sehr ähnlich. Da habe ich nicht gezaubert oder nichts Neues erfunden, sondern ich musste das machen, was ich tagtäglich mache, nur dann bin ich authentisch. Deswegen habe ich da auch nicht wahnsinnig viele andere Dinge gemacht. Das Drumherum ist das, was noch zusätzlich Energie zieht. Das gibt es im U19-Bereich nicht, aber dieses Drumherum, man kann sagen Druck, aber auch dieser Erfolgzdruck, dieses Gewinnen und Verlieren, dieses Schwarz-Weiß, das ist schon das, was noch viel mehr Energie reinhaut. Natürlich die ganze Medienarbeit, wie das dann dazukommt, das ist auch Arbeit als Trainer. Da muss ich auch Gedanken machen, was kommuniziere ich, was spreche ich an, was sind meine Themen, wie gehe ich da ran, wie verkaufe ich da auch gewisse Dinge, die ich der Mannschaft genauso verkaufe. Das muss auch irgendwo deckungsgleich sein, damit da die Message und die Gemeinsamkeit entsteht. Das sind schon Dinge, da investierst du auch Zeit und Energie, weil das muss funktionieren. Wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann kannst du trainieren, wie du willst, das muss alles zusammen funktionieren. Das ganze Puzzle muss die einzelnen Teile ineinander bringen, dann ist ein gutes Puzzle. Das war eigentlich das Ziel und diese Professionalität wollte ich schon haben, deswegen hat mich insbesondere das Thema drum herum, die Medienarbeit, auch TV nach dem Spiel und so was, das sind schon Dinge, die ziehen schon Energie, die hauen schon bei.
Und ist man da Einzelkämpfer oder wie kann man das angehen?
Ich war nicht Einzelkämpfer, ich saß nicht immer im Kämmerchen und habe mir überlegt, das und das erzähle ich morgen, sondern ich habe einfach auch einen guten Kumpel, der hat eine Agentur für sowas, der ist da auch nicht ganz professionell so und mit dem diskutiere ich dann Dinge und den diskutiere ich aber schon seit vielen Jahren, dass ich Sachen mit ihm diskutiere und jetzt haben wir eben dieses Thema diskutiert und da draußen entwickeln, haben wir dann Themen entwickelt und gewusst, die und die Fragen werden kommen. In die Richtung wollen wir auch Gespräche oder Medientermine lenken, Pressekonferenzen und dann hast du die Themen und dann weißt du doch auch ein bisschen, was du für Antworten gibst, damit du damit auch gewisse Ziele, eine gewisse Kommunikation erreichst.
Es waren sehr wilde Ergebnisse damals auch. Im ersten Spiel gegen Gladbach gewonnen, im zweiten Spiel dann in Berlin mit einem nicht gegebenen Handelfmeter, der einfach auch vom VRR übersehen wurde, knapp verloren, und dann ging es am Ende in die Relegation. Was waren denn so die verschiedenen Stationen innerhalb dieser verschiedenen Spiele? Wie viel geht es denn zum Beispiel in so einer Situation noch um Taktik?
Es geht immer um Taktik natürlich auch, und trotzdem ist es nicht Taktiküberfrachtung. Du hast keine Zeit mehr, irgendwas zu entwickeln, sondern du musst die Taktik auf ein Maß, auf ein Niveau bringen, dass es alle Spieler verstehen und umsetzen können. Wenn die Mannschaften bei uns jetzt auch international sind, dann war das Thema Sprache für mich ein wichtiger Punkt. Ich selber habe eine französische Mutter und kann Französisch sprechen, das heißt, ich konnte mich mit Pavard und Shadi Akolo in ihrer Muttersprache unterhalten. Damit habe ich Akolo wieder einmal ins Leben zurückgeholt, ins Fußballerleben, und er hat dann bei mir noch relativ viele Einsätze gehabt, teilweise noch gute Spiele gemacht. Mein Co-Trainer war spanischsprachig, damit konnte er die Südamerika-Fraktionen. Diese Puzzleteile führen zueinander. Zum einen fühlen sich die Spieler abgeholt, weil sie in ihrer Sprache kommuniziert wird mit ihnen. Zum anderen kannst du die Taktik auf ein Niveau runterbrechen und ihnen es auch so erklären, dass jeder diese Spieler versteht und umsetzen kann. Das war eigentlich Teil der Strategie. Ich habe jetzt nicht versucht, den Fußball neu zu erfinden, und das Detail und das Detail und noch das kleinere Detail dazu gefunden, sondern ich habe versucht, eine Basis zu finden, die alle Spieler verstehen und die alle top umsetzen können, um es dann auch gut auf den Platz zu kriegen. Das war so eine Grundstruktur des Gesamts.
Und wie hast du dann aus taktischer Sicht, emotional kann man sich das glaube ich vorstellen, die beiden Relegationsspieler erlebt? Also ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, beim Hinspiel geht der VfB in Führung und ich habe es zusammen mit einem sehr innigen VfB-Fan gesehen und die hat sofort zu mir gesagt, jetzt wird es eins zu eins fallen. Weil das ist einfach schon so häufig passiert beim VfB und tatsächlich lange Ball, Anderson, jetzt auch nicht das überraschendste taktischste Mittel von Union Berlin und dann kommt direkt dann wieder dieser, ja in dem Sit, in der Situation auch klare Nackenschlag. Wie würdest du jetzt so in der Rückschau mit vielen Monaten Puffer dazwischen das taktisch so ein bisschen analysieren? Was waren die Schlüsselmomente, die da waren und vielleicht aber auch gefehlt haben?
Ich glaube, in der Vorbereitung auf das Union-Spiel haben wir sicherlich auch über lange Bälle auf Andersen gesprochen. Aber die waren uns vielleicht neu in dem Moment, in dem wir eins nicht führen. Ich glaube, dass da vielleicht auch aus der Emotionalität heraus einfach ein Moment der Unaufmerksamkeit war. Und wenn man es dann aber sieht, wie Andersen und Abdullahi das machen, dann war das dann auch kurz einfach auch gut. Das muss man ehrlicherweise dann auch sagen. Trotzdem insgesamt aus der taktischen Sicht gesprochen hatten wir im ersten Spiel sehr, sehr große Probleme, genug Personal vorne so hinzukriegen, dass Union nicht so präzise auf Andersen spielt. Und der an diesem Tag das einfach auch sehr, sehr gut gemacht hat. Und da haben wir ein bisschen die Nuance geändert im Rückspiel. Und da ist es uns insbesondere in der ersten Halbzeit taktisch, glaube ich, wesentlich besser gelungen. Wir hatten zur Halbzeitpause, glaube ich, 6 zu 1 Torschüsse. Da haben wir dann mit Raute gespielt. Und damit waren wir vorne griffiger. Und hinten war es dann auch von den Zuordnungen, vom Vordecken, vom Abfangen und vom zweiten Ball, glaube ich, wesentlich besser und stabiler. Insbesondere auch Holger Watschu war natürlich im Rückspiel. Auch da einfach ein richtig gutes Spiel gemacht. Den hatte ich im Hinspiel leider auch nur auf der Bank. Deswegen sind das taktische, personelle Dinge, die wir angepasst haben und die das Spiel fast in die richtige Richtung gelenkt hätten. Die erste Halbzeit in Berlin war, glaube ich, schon ein guter Schritt, wenn wir da eins mit in Führung gehen. Mit dem Freistoß, der dann aber aberkannt wurde. Es ist so, wir haben zweimal das Spiel nicht gegen den zwei Legisten gewonnen. Damit sind wir dann auch mit den 27, 28 Punkte verdient, abgestiegen.
Tröstet es, dass jetzt auch viele Bundesligisten, also Erstligisten, nicht damit klarkommen, mit den langen Bällen auf Andersun?
Ja, tatsächlich, das tröstet. Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin im Verlauf der Vorrunde ein bisschen Union Berlin-Fan geworden, weil mit diesen Mitteln sie es schaffen, den Gegner auf ihr Niveau zu ziehen, runterzuziehen. Das haben sie auch in dem Spiel gegen uns gemacht. Das ist auch eine Qualität im Ergebnis-Sport. Das ist nicht immer schön anzuschauen, aber es ist eine Qualität. Das zeigt, dass, man hat gesagt, das sind die Schlechtesten von den drei, die da vorne mitspielen in der 2. Liga. Aber wenn man jetzt die Bundesliga sieht, sind es die besten vom Punktestand. Und das tun sich wahnsinnig viele Mannschaften sehr schwer. Ja, es tröstet etwas, es macht es nicht besser, aber es tröstet etwas. Weil es ist schon, es haben auch andere Mannschaften große Probleme gegen DCA zu spielen, zu widerstehen oder zu bestehen. Und die haben noch eine höhere Spielerqualität als wir.
Okay, und dann, ich lasse jetzt alle emotionalen Fragen weg. Das darfst du nämlich auch gerne für dich behalten, finde ich. Aber dann kommst du wieder zurück zu U19, musst irgendwie die Akkus wieder aufladen. Hat denn diese Zeit im Profifußball auch deine Ansprache jetzt an deine jetzige Mannschaft, deine alte und zum Teil neue Mannschaft, verändert?
Ich hatte ein bisschen Zeit, um die Akkus aufzuladen. Immerhin hatte ich ja dann knapp vier Wochen Urlaub oder Sommerpause dann. Deswegen war dann der Bock auf U19 ab August, Juli dann schon wieder da. Trotzdem muss man auch da sich wieder neu finden. Das ist eine neue Mannschaft, eine neue Situation. Man hat schon was zu erzählen natürlich dann in dem Moment. Vielleicht bilde ich es mir ein, aber die Jungs gucken schon ein bisschen anders hin und hören auch ein bisschen anders zu vielleicht. Und trotzdem habe ich jetzt nicht mein Wesen und meine Art des Coach-Signs verändert. Ich habe den gleichen Zugang zu den Spielern, ich bin gleich kritisch, ich bin gleich lobend.
Ich bin manchmal Freund, manchmal bin ich auch nicht so Freund der Spieler.
Also ich glaube, dass diese Art und Weise das Gleiche weiterhin ist. Vielleicht sehen die Spieler jetzt mittlerweile in mir einen ein bisschen anderen Trainer, der ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung hat für mich selber. Das ist eine Erfahrung und ich habe da auch viel gelernt in dieser Zeit und trotzdem ist es einfach ein Schritt in einem Lebensweg eines Trainers, der jetzt dann weiterarbeitet und ich glaube, so soll es die nächsten Jahre hoffentlich auch weiter gehen, dass ich mich regelmäßig mit weiteren Erfahrungen verbessere und das dann aufs Spiel übertragen kann.
Aber erstmal weiter im Nachwuchsbereich?
Ja, ich habe jetzt beim VfB meinen Vertrag verlängert und war gleich um vier Jahre. Der Hintergrund ist, dass sich VfB sehr um mich bemüht hat, dass wir auch einige Dinge in letzter Zeit angestoßen haben, die ich auch weiter mitarbeiten will. Deswegen ist es schon ein klares Commitment zum VfB-NLZ irgendwo. Ich bin da sehr gern tätig. Wenn da irgendetwas anderes irgendwann mal passiert, wie es in der Schnellebigkeit ist, des Fußballs, werde ich auch darüber nachdenken, das ist sehr klar. Dann muss man sich auch an einen Tisch setzen und sich einfach klipp und klar unterhalten und eine gemeinsame Lösung finden. Trotzdem ist diese Unterschrift, diese Verlängerung von mir einfach ein klares Begegnis. Ja, ich mache das gerne und bin auch gern bereit, noch weiter zu arbeiten. Ich sitze jetzt nicht auf gepackten Koffern und werde schnell wie möglich ganz oben rein. Diesen Größenwahnsinn habe ich jetzt nach sechs Spielen als Bundesliga-Trainer nicht entwickelt, sondern bin als Abstiegstrainer auf dem Boden der Tatsachen.
Ok, jetzt sitzen wir ja hier wieder beim Junior Cup und ich habe mich auch schon sehr gefreut, dass wir uns hier wieder treffen würden. Ich freue mich, dass wir uns duzen dürfen, weil du jetzt sagst, zweite Podcast-Aufnahme ab jetzt ganz enge Bünde. Ich habe über eine Sache länger nachgedacht, die du damals vor ziemlich genau einem Jahr in dem kurzen Gespräch, was wir gesagt haben. Und zwar ging es um die Gier der jungen Spieler, den Mut, eigene Grenzen zu überwinden. Und du hast es dann auch mit einer gesellschaftlichen Komponente verknüpft, dass du gesagt hast, man würde sehen, z.B. am Beispiel von Frankreich, dass da viele Spieler in die absolute Top-Spitze kommen, die eben aus sozialen Verhältnissen kommen, denen es einfacher runtergebrochen nicht so gut geht wie vielen deutschen Spielern. Hat sich bei der These etwas getan, oder würdest du weiter sagen, dass es einer der wesentlichen Unterschiede ist, warum manchen deutschen Talenten vielleicht in den entscheidenden Momenten, es hört sich ein bisschen einfacher an, aber der Biss fehlt?
Ja, bleibe ich weiterhin dabei. Ich glaube, dass ich da noch weitere Erfahrungen diesbezüglich gemacht habe, weitere Beispiele, dass es in allen Vereinen, die es gibt, die sich da zeigen, der Wert der Schule in Deutschland ist sehr hoch und unsere Spieler, wir wollen und wir müssen das als LIZ machen.
Das hat auch ein gesellschaftliches Ziel, diese Spieler mit einem Schulabschluss rauszubekommen.
Wir können nicht nur sagen, wir sind 14 und versuchen Profi zu werden oder landen in der Gosse, sondern wir müssen die einfach auf zwei Wegen ausbilden, sowohl schulisch als auch fußballerisch. Deswegen haben wir die Jungs auch relativ lange in der Schule, während es in anderen Ländern nicht so lange Schule gibt, weil die Jungs viel früher Profis sind oder versuchen, Profis zu sein. Ich glaube, das wirkt sich schon nach aus.
Wie du sagst, mit der Gier, es sind oft Spieler, die aus afrikanischen Ländern auch oft ankommen oder aus Kolonien.
Da steckt natürlich noch etwas ganz anderes dahinter, eine Familie, die das unbedingt haben will.
Wenn man dann aber unsere Spieler sieht, dann sind das auch Spieler aus sozialen Schichten.
Aus allen sozialen Schichten irgendwo.
Und trotzdem ist bei den Spielern in den Gesprächen, ja ich will Profi werden, aber auch immer der Notnagel, ja wenn es nicht klappt, dann gehe ich studieren oder dann mache ich da was.
Also das spricht ja auch für die Spieler. Das spricht ja auch für die Spieler und trotzdem ist es dann vielleicht ein Unterschied. Sie kämpfen nicht zwingend um ihre Existenz, sie kämpfen für das Ziel, aber sie wollen, am Ende müssen wir beides pushen und beides unterstützen, aber wir wollen sie auch im Leben haben und wir wollen sie ja nicht nur durch den Kamin heizen und wird Fußballprofi oder geh, wohin du willst. Also das ist ja für uns als NSL, dort als Trainer wichtig, dass die jungen Menschen auch als Persönlichkeiten unterstützt werden und wenn es als Fußballprofi nicht klappt, dass sie einen anderen Weg im Leben gehen.
Ja genau und an diesem Punkt habe ich nämlich weiter drüber nachgedacht, weil ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, es ist ja eigentlich gar nichts Erstrebenswertes, dass man eben alles auf die Karte Fußball setzt, weil eben die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist zu schaffen, egal wie gut man auch hier bei diesem Turnier spielt. Ich meine, für deine Mannschaft sitzt gerade sehr gut. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer noch sehr gering, im Profi Fußball zu landen. Und gleichzeitig, finde ich, gibt es eine Schnittmenge bei dieser Frage der Gier und auch der Art der Spielertypen, die man da hat. Nämlich die Frage nach, Deutschland würde mehr Individualisten brauchen, mehr Spieler, die im 1 gegen 1 Situation lösen und die vor allem auch vielleicht mal einen Weg gehen, der auch nicht immer taktisch erstmal der Sinnvollste ist, aber der vielleicht in der Sekunde, in diesem Spiel dann alles aus der Ordnung bringen kann. Und ich frage mich, wie man das überhaupt schaffen will. Ich habe jetzt ganz viel dazu gehört, von Michael Schönweiß, von Oliver Bierhoff, von ganz verschiedenen Trainern. Aber so richtig eine Methodik, wie man das umsetzen kann, erschließt sich mir daraus nicht. Wie schafft man das? Individualismus zu fördern, obwohl wir doch eigentlich an allen anderen Ecken versuchen. Taktische und andere Gesamtkonzepte unterzubringen.
Ich kann ein Beispiel nennen, das war ein Ansatz, eine Idee, die mir selber so passiert ist. Als ich ganz junger Trainer war, da war ich 23 Jahre, 24 Jahre, bei meinem Heimatverein Walingen. Da hatte ich einen Spieler, der war sehr gut, trotzdem hatte ich auch andere Spieler, die mussten auch irgendwo zusammenspielen, so wie es ein Trainer einer E-Jugend von seiner Mannschaft fordert. Und immer wenn das Spiel aber knapp wurde, dann habe ich meinem besten Spieler, Florian Katt, SC Freiburg, dann habe ich dem mehr oder weniger das Sieg in ein gegeben.
Flor, du kannst da einen Lauf machen, übersetzt hieß das, nimm den Ball und versuch, one against all zu spielen. So habe ich dem im Prinzip so dieses, jetzt ist deine Zeit, jetzt kannst du individuell das Ding entscheiden. Das Spiel ist zu knapp, wir werden das als Mannschaft nicht hinbekommen, jetzt kriegst du nur noch das Individualistesinn.
Trotzdem hat die Mannschaft dann für ihn gespielt.
Und ich sag mal, ohne dass ich es jetzt durchdacht hatte bis ins kleinste Teil und nicht, dass ich 15 Jahre später mich dafür rechtfertige oder das nochmal rauszuholen, aber das ist so mein Beispiel, wo ich ihm beigebracht habe zu dribbeln, ihm beigebracht habe Verantwortung zu übernehmen und als Individualist ein Spiel zu entscheiden.
Und wenn man dann die Jahre weiter von ihm anschaut, dann ist er in einen Bundesligakader reingerutscht, weil er im Gegensatz zu vielen vielen LLZ-Spielern, und er war nie ein LLZ-Spieler, er hat geschafft in Momenten über dribblings Spiele zu verändern und Elfmeter zu ziehen und Überzahlssituationen zu schaffen.
Damit habe ich ihm eine Waffe an die Hand gegeben bzw.
diese Waffe gefördert, die er hatte und die vielleicht oft von uns, wenn wir zu viel taktisch, wenn wir zu viel über das Kollektiv im Nachwuchsbereich sprechen, vielleicht abtrainieren. Das war so ein Moment, der mir aus Zufall passiert ist als junger Trainer, aber der sich im Nachgang, im Rückblick sehr positiv entwickelt hat. Ich glaube, das ist es, eine Mischung zu finden und die Spieler ihren Talenten zu fördern. Der Ausbildungsplan mag das eine sein, aber wenn du einen super Trippel hast, dann musst du ihm Freiräume geben zum Trippen und trotzdem muss er den Kontext verstehen. Ich glaube, dass das der Weg ist. Die Struktur muss so sein, dass jedem Trainer bewusst ist, ich muss den Spielern nach seinen Stärken auf den Platz bringen, egal ob er 10 Jahre alt ist oder 16 Jahre alt ist. Wenn du das hinkriegst, dann entwickelst du auch das Individuelle im Kollektiv. So versuche ich es mir zu erklären. Am Ende setzen sich die dann durch, die dieses Individuelle mit der besten Waffe hinbekommen und trotzdem im Kollektiv am besten funktionieren, damit das Gesamte als Mannschaft funktioniert.
Taktisch gesehen hat man vor allem die Aufgabe, diese Spieler in diese Situation zu bekommen. Wenn du jemanden mit hohem Tempo auf dem Flügel hast, dann versuchst du ihn zu isolieren, dass er im 1 gegen 1 sein Tempo ausspiegeln kann. Das, was gerade so ein bisschen fehlt, wenn man in einem größeren Kontext auf den deutschen Fußball guckt, ist ja so ein bisschen die Präsenz im offensiven Zentrum. Logischerweise stehen da auch häufig mindestens ein Sechser herum und machen ihre Sache sehr gut. Die Ketten sind heutzutage sehr eng. Aber wie kann man das dann schaffen, taktisch gesehen in diese interessanten Räume reinzukommen? Ist das dann vielleicht der Auftrag an dich, mannschaftstaktisch gesehen, es zu schaffen, diese Räume zu besetzen? Und dann können die Spieler mit ihrer individuellen Klasse in diesen Räumen das eine gewonnene Dribbling machen. Der eine durchgesteckte Pass macht an der Stelle den Unterschied. Deine Aufgabe ist es, die Schachfiguren so hinzuschieben, dass derjenige den Ball am Fuß hat, der das am besten umsetzen kann.
Wenn wir jetzt wieder von U19-Bereich reden, dann geht es natürlich auch um die Entwicklung von Spielern. Wenn du sagst, du willst einen neuen nach vorne entwickeln, dann musst du natürlich auch Formen schaffen, die nicht nur isoliert sind. Der und ein Innenverteidiger duellieren sich und setzen sich durch. Du musst natürlich auch Spielformen schaffen, die die Situation regelmäßig provozieren.
Und je größer der Kontext ist im 11 gegen 11, ist es eben nicht so oft, wenn du jetzt die Spielformen so kreierst, dass sie eben 5 gegen 5 stattfinden und der dann in die Position reinkommt.
Du kannst ja jetzt schon gewisse Schwerpunkte setzen. Wenn du sagst, du bist ein wirklich sehr, sehr guter Spieler, dann machst du solche Formen vielleicht auch öfters, dass du diesen sehr, sehr guten Spieler dann noch öfters in die Situationen reinbringst und weiterentwickelst.
Und dann lässt du halt, wenn du nur 2 mittelmäßige Flügelspieler hast, dann machst du Flügelformtraining nicht so oft, wie du das für den Zentrumsspieler vorne drin hast.
Damit da einfach eine Entwicklung, das ist das Talent. Und so kannst du dich schon ein bisschen orientieren und danach dein Training ausrichten. Und nicht nur vom Wochenende, ich brauch gegen den Gegner des und des, sondern eher von den Spielern aus das Training zu planen. Was sind Positionen, die auf hohem Niveau sind und das wir noch höher kriegen wollen und entsprechend so dann auch zu trainieren. Und nicht nur, wir spielen am Wochenende gegen einen tief stehenden Gegner und müssen den mit dem 4-4-2 über 27 Ecken in den Rücken hinten rein. Doris Pastor, also das ist die Theorie.
Und da geht es als U19 Trainer um Spielerentwicklung und deswegen liegt da auch der Fokus und das ist auch der Ausgangspunkt für das, was auch immer passiert.
Hat sich da denn beim VfB auch was in der Philosophie verändert? Man versucht jetzt mit dem Profiteam deutlich einen Ballbesitzfußball zu etablieren. Jetzt auch noch von einem Trainer wechselt, der aber auch quasi in dessen Geist steht. Also wo Thomas Hitzesberger sagt, wir haben den Kader auf einem Ballbesitzfußball hin ausgerichtet. Und deswegen soll quasi auch der Nachfolge und neue Trainer dieser Philosophie sich verschreiben und soll dazu einfach passen. Hat das jetzt auch deine Arbeit in der U19 verändert? Seid ihr euch da gleich geblieben? Insgesamt ist es im Nachwuchs vom VfB so, dass du automatisch im Ballbesitz dominierend bist, weil du einfach den Gegner oder vielen Mannschaften einfach auch vom Spielerpotenzial her überlegen bist.
Deswegen ist es jetzt nicht... Wir haben bisher nicht tiefstehend Kontern gespielt als VfB. Wir waren immer schon mit Ball relativ dominant. Und dass das jetzt die erste Mannschaft übernommen hat, das ist übernommen jetzt auch als ihr Thema, also die Philosophie ist nichts Neues und verändert jetzt unsere Arbeit nicht massiv. Es verändert natürlich schon die Nuancen, weil wir passen uns an, wir unterhalten uns, wir versuchen Ideen natürlich aufzunehmen, dass Spieler, die hin und wieder Profis trainieren, aber oft bei uns, dass denen der Übergang natürlich auch leichter fällt. Oder gewisse Dinge dazu übernehmen, zu kopieren als Vorbereitung. Das ist unser Job und das machen wir da auch gerne.
Aber die Philosophie ist jetzt nun nie grundlegend anders gewesen im Nachwuchsbereich bei uns, von dem her ist es jetzt nicht komplett was anderes. Okay, und dann würde mich interessieren, welche Rolle spielen dabei Lockbälle? Wenn du als Ballbesitzteam spielst, dann gegen einen meistens relativ tief stehenden Gegner. Es ist selten, dass man mal, oder eher so phasenweise, dass man höher angelaufen wird. Das heißt, in der Regel steht dir da irgend so ein 4-4-2 oder ein 5-4-1, irgendwie sowas in der Art steht dir da entgegen. Und die Ketten sind ja heutzutage relativ eng bei den meisten Mannschaften. Das heißt, man hat einfach Schwierigkeiten genau in die Bereiche des Feldes zu kommen, wo es eben dann einfach Torgefahr auch herauskriegert werden kann. Und jetzt gibt es Vereintetrainer, Julian Nagelsmann ist da sicherlich einer, der das am häufigsten einsetzt, die die Lock-Bälle spielen lassen. Also Bälle, die so ein bisschen vor die Ketten gehen und man hofft, dass sich dahinter etwas in Bewegung setzt oder man lässt einen Spieler entgegenkommen und in dessen Rücken stößt jemand in die Diagonale. Ist das vielleicht so der Schlüssel, den die meisten Teams, der vielen Teams einfach noch fehlt, weshalb es in solchen Spielen oft sehr statisch zugeht?
Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass in solchen Spielen oft die Angst ist, ja, ich will nicht den Ball verlieren. Weil der Gegner hat auch gesagt, ja, kein Konter kriegen gegen die.
Also spielst du natürlich auch wesentlich sicherer mit angezogener Handbremse.
Und die besten Momente entstehen eigentlich eher darum, wenn du, wie du sagst, den Gegner mal lockst, wenn vielleicht mal ein Pass gar nicht so präzise ist und der Gegner jetzt das Gefühl hat, oh, jetzt komm ich ran.
Der berühmte absichtliche Fehlpass, ja.
Ganz so krass gesprochen, aber daraus entsteht auf einmal eine Dynamik, nämlich auch, weil der Gegner rauskommt und sich was erhofft. Und jetzt entsteht für dich auch Dynamik, weil es jetzt Räume hat.
Deswegen muss es, glaube ich, in solchen Momenten auch mal ein bisschen riskanter zugehen.
Riskanter mit einer klaren Absicherung natürlich dann in den hinteren Räumen irgendwie. Aber trotzdem musst du da hinkommen und nicht nur Safety und quer, quer, quer und irgendwann wird mal ein Loch aufgehen, sondern den Gegner auch irgendwo auch dazu zu bringen, selber mal aktiv zu werden, dass er versucht, in die Ballohrung zu kommen, dass er versucht, einen Konter anzusetzen, dass er mal rauskommt, weil er glaubt, er kommt jetzt an den Ball, damit es dann wegen mir zwei schnellen Kontakten über ein Direktspiel auf einmal einen offenen Raum gibt. Das gehört schon dazu und ich glaube, da musst du so rangehen, dass du nicht die Konter verhindern, sondern wie du sagst, den Ballverlust dann auch sofort wieder zu kontrollieren oder dann eben auch einen kreativen Moment zu entwickeln, ruhig riskant zu spielen, kreative Momente zu entwickeln, dass dann Gegner eben auch in Bewegung kommen und aus dem raus schaffst du es dann am Ende der Kette.
Das ist halt immer so abstrakt, wenn man so drüber spricht, finde ich. Ich frage mich, wie kann man das systematisieren? Also sind das dann Bälle, die man bewusst in Schnittstellen reinspielt, die man in den Halbraum reinspielt? Sind das vielleicht auch mal Dribblings? Ich habe das Gefühl, dass jetzt so als Entwicklungsstufe, wenn wir mal bei Julian Nagelsmann bleiben, ist so quasi die Weiterentwicklung vom Hoffenheimer Fußball zum Leipziger Fußball, dass häufiger auch Spieler aus der vorletzten oder der letzten Kette sogar andribbeln und damit ja den Gegner zu einer Reaktion zwingen. Was ist da so deine Philosophie? Was versuchst du mit der U19 umzusetzen?
Das sind, glaube ich, hochkomplexe, mannschaftstaktische Sachen.
Das Training einer U19 ist nicht hochkomplex, mannschaftstaktisch. Da geht es wirklich viel, viel mehr um Basis-Dinge, um individuell-technisch-taktische Dinge, aber auch um gruppentaktische Dinge.
Das ist für uns der totale Schwerpunkt. Da gehe ich eben so ran, dass ich dann eben den Spielern, die animiere, dazu riskant zu spielen, riskante Sachen zu machen, sich auch für kreativ zu sein und gemeinsam dann auch Lösungen zu entwickeln, überschnelles, direktes Spiel, was manchmal dann auch eben auch in die Hose geht und trotzdem kann eine Mannschaft dann als Block wieder funktionieren. Also es wirklich hochkomplex auf das gesamt-taktische Maximalniveau zu kriegen.
In dieser Zeit möchtest du die U19 dann nicht haben.
Und wie ist es dann auf der individual-taktischen Ebene? Ich hatte ein interessantes Gespräch neulich mit jemandem, der sich so ein bisschen mit dem neuro-wissenschaftlichen Zusammenhängen im Fußball beschäftigt und der unter anderem gesagt hat, man kann feststellen bei besonders guten Passspielern, dass die im Moment des Passes nie auf den Mitspieler gucken, wo sie hinpassen, sondern immer nur auf den Ball. Also das sind so ganz kleine Details, wo man wirklich bei jedem einzelnen Spieler im Grunde in die Analyse gehen müsste und diese kleinen Dinge dann verändert. Wie schaffst du es denn dann so was in den Trainingsalltag, bei dem ja ganz viele andere Dinge auch trainiert werden müssen, zu integrieren?
Ist es überhaupt möglich?
Ist es möglich? Ich glaube, das ist ein Ziel, das immer dann entsteht, wenn du Trainingsformen machst, die vielleicht Chaos sind, aber die auch sehr, sehr viele Drucksituationen haben. Ich glaube, dann entwickeln Spieler, die da ein gewisses Grundtalent haben, einfach solche Fähigkeiten nochmal weiter, wenn sie nur dadurch eine Lösung für die Situation haben. Und ich glaube, der Kern liegt schon drin, dass du die Spieler in sehr komplexe, auch Überforderungssituationen bringst. Überforderung oder Chaos. Aber dann, wenn ein Spieler talentiert ist, dann glaube ich, kann er da draus, seine eigene Waffe und seine eigene Qualität entwickeln, trotzdem noch die Ruhe zu haben und ebenso dieses Chaos und diese enge Drucksituation so zu überwinden, indem er schafft, woanders hinzugucken, als er eigentlich hinspielt. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Instinkt, das ein Spieler dann entwickelt. Den kannst du jetzt aber nicht, ist mein Gefühl, massiv coachen. Das kannst du dir mal ein, zwei Mal vielleicht in einer Video-Sequenz zeigen.
Aber ich glaube, dass das auch so ein Weg ist, den der Spieler für sich selber entwickelt, wo er dann ein Gespür entwickelt.
Das ist gut, das klappt gut, aber an dem arbeite ich dann so weiter.
Und du kannst halt über die Formen, die das für einen Sechser hergeben, aber auch die Formen, die die ähnliche Situation für außen haben, dass du das dann so ein bisschen implizit irgendwo vermittelst. Okay, das verstehe ich jetzt dann aber so, dass es so ein bisschen in der Eigenverantwortung der Spieler liegt, auf diese Details zu achten. Also jeder kann ja Champions League gucken, jeder kann sich ja seine sportlichen Vorbilder vornehmen. Und dann könnt ihr Hilfestellungen geben, ihr könnt Dinge ansprechen, aber im Grunde, die Lösungen müssen selbst gefunden werden, sonst hat es ja vielleicht auch keinen pädagogischen und nachhaltigen Effekt beim Spieler. Wenn der Spieler kommt und mir sagt, ich habe deine super Situation gesehen und ich glaube, ich will das auch machen, und du förderst ihn da drin, in dem er anfängt, das zu machen und das ein-,
zwei-, dreimal vielleicht nicht funktioniert und trotzdem so ein Gefühl, er will da dranbleiben, dann musst du das natürlich logischerweise total unterstützen, aber du kannst jetzt nicht jedem Spieler sagen, pass auf, er sollt jetzt so passen wie ich es da als Trainer in der Champions League gesehen habe. Das muss ein Spieler schon ein Gefühl dafür entwickeln, ja, das kann ich und ja, das will ich, als dass du es ihm überstülbst.
Es muss von ihm rauskommen und du gibst ihm, du nimmst ihn in der Hand und versuchst ihn da drin irgendwo zu unterstützen. Ja, ist ein spannendes Thema. Ich habe mal gelesen, dass Kingsley Coman unter anderem deshalb so viel besser gepflankt hat unter Jupp Heynckes, weil Jupp Heynckes ihm gesagt hat, mach den letzten Schritt vor der Flanke nicht so schnell, weil er immer im höchsten Tempo gepflankt hat und er hat ihm in einer der allerersten Trainingszeiten gesagt, den letzten Schritt machst du einen kleinen Ticken langsamer, du bist ja trotzdem an deinem Gegenspieler schon vorbei, du bist ja schnell genug und ab dann kamen die Flanken viel präziser und ich fand das sehr faszinierend, dass man halt selbst auf dieser hohen Ebene bei so hochtalentierten Spielern mit so Detailbeobachtungen, die vielleicht auch häufig aus einer Erfahrung des Trainers kommen, eben noch so viel verändern kann. So kam ich eben auf die Frage. Gut, ich könnte wie immer lange mit dir sprechen. Vielleicht müssen wir mal ein Tribünengespräch machen. Weißt du schon, was das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch ist? Das tut mir leid, ein bisschen ungerechtig, das on air zu fragen. Also da habe ich unter anderem mit Holger Bartschow eine Sendung gemacht. Tipp mal, wie lang die war.
Ach doch, ich habe gehört, 4 Stunden, 3,5 Stunden.
Hast du gehört, ja?
Ich habe sogar mal kurz reingehört.
Ab Stunde 1 ging es dann so richtig ab. Das müssten wir irgendwann mal machen, glaube ich, mit ein bisschen Zeit. Bevor du dann wieder Chef-Trainer bist, beim VfB oder wo auch immer, dann entfleuchst du meines Zugriffs.
Egal wo ich bin, wenn ich es weiß, dann nehme ich mir auch 3,5 Stunden Zeit für dich.
Aha, jetzt habe ich es on tape. Das war der Wunsch. Ich danke Nico Willig. Viel Erfolg morgen am zweiten Tag. Wenn das hier ausgeschaltet wird, wissen wir schon, wie die U19 abgeschlossen hat. Danke und alles Gute für die Zukunft. Vielen Dank.